you
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
hello welcome back to the lobby you
GameSpot's weekly video game hangout
here in San Francisco California I'm
your host Mike McCarty here as always
with downtown Peter Brown hello friend
Rob handler boss hop and Kelly plaguey
hello how you guys doing good good yeah
yeah yeah freaking what is it was this
grin I don't know
is it a mu know that secret about you as
usual we have the YouTube and twitch and
GameSpot chats here in our studio so for
those joining feel free to chime in chat
and we will call you back if you have a
good comment as always I do have a
giveaway today it's actually pretty cool
I'll have John Luke pull up a photo of
it Yoji Shinkawa oddly enough did art
for the four characters from nazi
zombies or so i call duty zombies
they're pretty cool looking and we have
one of each character and we're giving
away for those so if you don't follow
GameSpot on Twitter go do that and then
retweet the tweet that they are going to
tweet from Shiva who runs our Twitter
account
she'll be putting the link in the twitch
chat as well if you're in there but
later on the week we'll pick a random
winner so go follow us on Twitter if you
don't like I said and retweet that and
if for some reason you don't know who
chicawa is he's the idea behind metal
gear since middle your solid yeah so did
you suffer knew that you probably
already want these posters yeah I mean
if you didn't like I'm just by seeing
him yeah it's also cool why did does
anybody know how that connection was
made like how did they get Yoji Shinkawa
to do stuff for call duty Treyarch have
a weird connection
I got no idea I mean he's no longer tied
to the you know anchor of Konami so I'm
sure his friend Kojima lets him do we
want both of them can do what they want
now right it's true for the most part -
Metal Gear I was Andrew house that's
okay for the PlayStation yeah dude yeah
house house a jus house house I saw The
Gaslight Anthem his band live once and
the opener his name was Andrew house but
everybody in the audience was like
calling for an encore but they
mispronounced his name which was funny
they kept saying Hoss that's a great
story yeah I do have some news items far
cry 5 they released key art this morning
was it this morning last night if it
goes this morning yeah yeah um it's
doozy
it's it's the Last Supper parody out
there by our friend Leonardo da Vinci
over in Italy yeah I don't know if John
Luke has that but we can pull that up
shows hope County Montana which if
you've been paying attention to uh what
are you doing I was trying to imitate it
like oh it's like everyone's like you're
making me the the Jesus of the painting
right now if you want to be I don't know
seems Jesse oh here we go so you can see
it's kind of a big lot of religious I
maybe call this kind of yes intonations
yeah you can see like a church in the
background obviously there's a guy who
has sinner carved into his back so it's
it's almost too much like it's very
heavy-handed in my opinion it's just
like this is about religion unless this
is a political statement on their behalf
I don't know that I want them to tread
down this path I know even before the
for teaser videos they release were
actually I kind of like them there were
a shots of this pastoral Montana
countryside but then um something
sinister came on over like it was
showing this
yeah the river right here and then all
sudden dead body comes out of nowhere
and this is welcome to Hope County
Montana this one just gets gunned down
go down the field see as you can tell
it's modern-day it's not like a wild
western like the rumors were uh you know
speculating and then here you see and
this one's kind of hard to see actually
if you're not really looking it's just
well like now it is not but this just
banging some dudes head against the bill
oh really
yeah it seems like a weird way to kill
someone or maybe the guy was already
dead and he's just playing with him who
knows
I ran out of hammers yeah uh so that the
DA will have to do more far cry 5 news
coming out soon ish really though yeah
Friday right oh yeah there's the
announcement Friday right Ubisoft has
been saying yeah those four teasers all
have the same date so it's cool um I'm
actually excited for that the last I
actually I like Far Cry primal more than
a lot of people or at least I think I
paid more attention to oh I reviewed it
but I really liked it and I'm kind of
curious to see what they do with this
although like you said Pete I don't know
that I really like the direction so far
a lot of it looks like I don't know what
they're trying to do if like they're
trying to cop someone people were just
wondering how much the religious stuff
would play into it but also just the
political aspect obviously looks very
super modern-day critique maybe yeah I'm
very apprehensive about it even just
like looking at that image I mean I
thought the teasers were cool like I
thought the live-action like oh this
kind of romanticized rural America but
something is off I like stuff like that
but then this art is like okay you're
really doubling down on that yeah like
like tripling yeah so that makes me
nervous yeah so we'll see more from
Ubisoft about fire craft 5 on Friday
there's an announcement coming
another news Red Dead Redemption was
delayed to sometime in 2018 it's no
longer gonna release in September I
believe the original release day was as
always just I'm assuming they just
needed more time to finish it up how do
you know do we know how long they've
been working on it at this point
sorry right every time - didn't mean to
say wait a long time yeah since GTA 5
maybe while like part of their team has
been doing GTA online don't know but
yeah we did get a few new screens here
looks gorgeous
it doesn't really this is in-game we I
don't know if they've clarified right
they just said here are some screenshots
yeah it was it was weird though cuz that
local paper Eddie in Montana when they
were shooting those Far Cry 5 videos a
lot of people follow he's gonna be for
Red Dead Redemption - but it turned out
it was for far cry 5 which I think less
people were expecting but yeah you can
go see these screens if you wanna take a
closer look at them on Gamescom yeah
like that doesn't look in game it will
yeah cut well I mean that would be a
cutscene if anything right that looks in
game those are my hands what MIT what
this is kind of like nice because I we
haven't seen that first trailer we were
all talking about how what we would want
is a very diverse environment right like
just like different locations in force
like you kind of got a glimpse of that
through these game screenshots and that
was really nice I don't know yeah
there's been excited that first art they
released was like seven people right and
the trailer showed seven people riding
across on horses presumably your gang
maybe who knows we don't know a ton
about the game yet but well that'd be
that will probably won't be at e3 will
it if they're gonna delay it to next
year's are usually doesn't do anything
yeah those sort of trade shows yeah
I'm assuming that maybe they'll do like
a stream later on this year something
like they did for the original
announcement who knows
and then also overwatch anniversary
as I was live went up yesterday morning
a few new modes of one-on-one mode three
new maps obviously new skins but I think
it's like Eldorado and I convolve kind
of variance and that would have been
what's the Egyptian map escapes me right
now
oh god it's I'm yeah but anyway they're
a bunch of really good and blinking
skins uh Nick margarita was scroll to
them you see like yeah bastions like a
dune buggy the best one which Nick Mario
show me a diva is now it's called
cruiser and divas Mac is like an
old-school Chrysler from the 50s even
has an air freshener yeah and then none
yeah diva herself is dressed kind of
like um something from Greece maybe I'm
going to coffee yeah it's a rabbit uh
and then may has the beekeeper outfit
and then the net on the mask on the Hat
is kind of like a holographic like
plasma shield yeah that's really great I
have a couple weeaboo notes um maze
dance like her new dance emote is from
the melancholy of haruhi suzumiya which
is an anime that's right it's the dance
it's the wada wada youkai from the
ending theme on the other side sorry why
is May taking like anime inspiration I
mean there's like tons of it like little
anime okay weeaboo internet things I
guess arias dances the aerobics the the
like aerobics meme where the guy like if
you've seen the championship aerobics
anyway it's all Internet I like sorry I
know she's like she didn't mean yeah but
I do want to note that the kanji on Han
Zoe's anniversary skin is incorrect it's
clearly Google translated its arrow as
in like if you drew a directional arrow
not like bow and arrow
so do you know offhand what the kanji
for bow and arrow would be yeah it looks
sort of like a spring so it's like a
bunch of squiggly lines that look like a
spring and then the kanji for arrow but
this has the the arrow kanji and then um
a ii kanji that's incorrect I haven't
seen it is it like on his tattoo it's on
his like belt strap okay gotcha damn
well call it blizzard and have them
change it yeah it's being a blizzard
well we'll get into a more destiny to
later which I'm sure a lot dealer here
for because uh John Luke and Tay went
down to LA last week for the event to
play it
little bit they had hands-on impressions
you can go see those on gamespot if you
want to look farther into it we will get
to destiny to probably last segment of
the show we have a lot of smaller things
to run through today starting with a
game that Pete and Rob you just played
today for the first time Kelly if you
play dead cells yet I love this game
yeah fun I mean I wish I started playing
it sooner in 10 of those scenarios where
everyone's talking about it I'm like
okay sounds good I'll file it away I'll
get back to it it's early access still
yeah but it doesn't feel like it feels
really full it feels really good for
those who don't know it's it's a
side-scrolling 2d people calling it
there are some light Metroidvania item
gating elements but it's more of a rogue
legacy if you played that on it is a
roguelike game so it's procedurally
generated levels but you see the
character just picked up a cell there
you can kind of see the bottom left of
the screen the blue orbs those are kind
of souls from Dark Souls I guess if you
want to compare to that because there
are some you know you lose those and
then but it is very much rogue legacy is
one of my favorite games and this is
more like that - the mutations of your
ancestors but you get to start you get
past like this first area you get to the
sewers or the promenade and then you get
to you know you can pick up actual
permanent upgrades which abilities you
can kind of grow these vines out of
these small little clumps or like I said
those are the Metroid actually
Metroidvania item getting ailments but
you'll also pick up like here you'll get
a magic increase for your abilities if
I'm blueprints for their items yeah you
find blueprints and then you you invest
those cells into different upgrades and
then once you invest those cells that's
permanent those cells those cell
upgrades are pretty extensive like as
far as the pages yeah there's a lot um I
got I think my Pete and I were talking
about thing my favorite weapon so far is
the dual wielding knives cuz I just got
that the third is always like a critical
and it's kind of this combo you can do
and I've been so you see on map 2 lb
down there you can see like he'll files
you can upgrade it so you can have more
than one each life and then when you get
to the checkpoints you can refill those
it's very much like Estus flasks from
dark souls or blood vials from
blood-borne which you can't really tell
just by watching this is how tight yeah
the controls are very responsive and it
like it doesn't feel like there's any
sort of like weird weightiness or
floating
that you have to get used to so that
immediately made me like hooked but then
it's just like the presentation and the
sort of like the the quick little combat
you know scenarios introduces very
quickly teaches you that there are a lot
of enemies you have to deal with in very
different ways yeah not to mention as
you can see now the game's gorgeous it's
it's you Danny the animations are so
impressive just like the just getting
the daggers like you're your pose when
you're holding them and running and then
just like I don't know finishing a kill
is just super rewarding with those
things yeah looking at all the work
that's already gone into this it makes
me wonder about the team that's created
it because there there is a lot of
effort clearly that's been put into this
game motion twin right the developer but
like I don't know yeah background but
I'm super curious now after seeing this
I'm like look into it you mean yeah yeah
it's a it's fantastic I don't know what
they'll keep adding with early access
maybe they'll flesh out there's not much
of a story at all there's a guy at the
beginning that tells you like uh you
seems you've lost your head there's
anything that's right and then he goes
because that explains why you can't talk
to me yeah like it's like the the
writing is really endearing like I've
been really enjoying it like people are
pretty mean right you come to a merging
he's like now get the hell out of here
yeah he's kind of yeah the merchants
right yeah
he cannot that's what the guy you invest
your cells with and then you die you
lose all those cells you like rogue
legacy you can get this upgrade where
you keep us percentage your gold when
you respawn though there's a carrot
right there that's like a one-time
health upgrade but you see these numbers
about the weapons and the the trigger
the magic abilities and your health
those you actually have to start over
and upgrade later on but yeah the
farthest I've found the game they've
kind of hinted at I'm halfway through
and again I've played probably six hours
at this point and I have upgraded my
twin blades to about they're doing like
plus twenty percent damage so they're
awesome but the thing is you like I said
it's procedurally generated so I might
not even find those so it's kind of a
risk the way you're investing in but
that's half the fun the enemy variety
the farther you get in is really good
those red ones are the range kind of
zombies that you see in this area but
then you start getting into a lot of
enemies that can shoot through walls
which makes it a little tougher and here
you see oh here's that one guy did you
get that ice blast there the first item
there and then I I tried using
it but the whole time it takes to it
usual long yeah yeah I mean I prefer to
just oh and then and then there's
there's these little touches that you
kind of these emergent things you don't
realize on if you do a ground slam you
stun people anytime you're dropping just
hold down and press down and a I guess a
small tip and then doors don't open them
just hit them because they'll stun it
almost flashbangs the enemies behind it
and get like a small amount of something
some resource from dodging is huge I
never use shield if I can help it but
dodging you go through anybody
especially when you start fighting the
shield guys I I didn't know you were I
mean I obviously there was going to be
controller support I just didn't figured
to plug that up I imagine that would be
a lot better
oh yeah yeah controller playing the ps4
controller just felt immediately good
and it was weren't but like no problems
yeah I've been using xbox one it feels
great as well then this guy you need
spend your cells here here you go so you
can see so the health file up top left
dish right there
with the 52 you need 52 cells to be able
to carry two I actually got that so
every between these checkpoints right
after this merchant you'll see that
there's this giant flask of health
potion that you refill at this game is
fantastic as someone who really likes
Metroidvania switch that's less of the
comparison I would make them to robe
legacy or something there are like I
said uh Kelly you just saw those clumps
it said tickle that's you grow vines on
them later those are the permanent
ability to keep and that's where the
item gating comes in like a like a
Metroid game yeah yeah but it is more if
you liked rogue legacy which if you
haven't played that you should it's on
Xbox one and ps4 now as of last year two
years ago it's on Vita 2 and Vita yeah
you should play that game rogue legacy
would be fantastic on switch now that I
think about it it's pretty good on V the
mic yeah I don't have a Vita you know
this no I love my I've been considering
buying a Vita recently um for because I
after prescribe ok persona 4 I want to
play spelunky danganronpa
final fancies attacked today's yes God
love God dies I think I asked Pete maybe
weekly what the best platform to play
tactics on is and what's the answer you
always give me play the PlayStation
classics version on Vita
yeah or on your ps3 that you still have
hooked up because you're cool like me oh
cool I do have my hope that well it's
not hooked up but it's stacked on my
like entertainment center I just a plug
it in there you go um yeah play dead
cells this games awesome like I said
it's in early X
but if I didn't say that and they didn't
have a notifier at the beginning you
might not even know it it doesn't feel
like there's much missing um I don't I
haven't found anything I disliked about
it the only thing I dislike is kind of
inherent to like a roguelike is
sometimes you won't come across items
that you like and you'll almost feel
like you're not having the full
experience in this playthrough but again
that's the game's design I guess the
blood sword this thing it that whoever I
don't know whose footage this is whoever
is I think this is Jake maybe whoever is
playing right here the blood swords good
it just causes bleeding damage it's mine
I know for a fact this is not you I
watched you play earlier yeah you're
only like 20 minutes in though right Shh
20 minutes too far what you like do you
like this from a play no I really do
like it
oh the controller yeah I know I am doing
it I want to play more of this for sure
it's tough but it feels so good that you
don't mind dying and starting oh yeah
like you can see here it's getting this
is not even the craziest gets oh here
use weird scarecrow things that shield
enemies so right there you can't hurt
them until you kill it up top it's like
a practice dummy that like a knight
might use or something it's which is
great it's before you sorry I don't me
to keep cutting you off okay but it's
really that enemy variety later on gets
really great um the my point kind of
past but just talking about like you
don't mind dying because it feels so
good is like something that's really
inherently important to this kind of
game yeah that that intrigue like
obviously I'm pulled in by the the art
style and it it's gorgeous and it looks
great but that I think is the thing
that's going to keep me playing did you
get the chance to play rogue legacy ever
mm-hmm you should try that and this um I
like I said rogue legacy cellar-door
games I believe two people made it I
think and it came out 2013 which is a
year were a few of those kind of games
come out rogue legacy and risk of rain
which has a sequel they announced well
risk of rain itself is made by two
people as well when they were at
Washington University I think I was two
college students they made it and it was
kind of a sleeper robe like hit back at
the kind of the peak of the roguelike
craze this game honestly design wise and
like I said robe like kind of 2d
side-scrolling feels like it might have
come out a few years ago not to say
anything about its quality at all it
just feels like a few years ago this
kind
game was like everybody was wanting yeah
I mean it might be fair to say that you
know all that energy and interest back
then inspired the creation of this maybe
mhm yeah what is like five years ago at
this point now some of those games yeah
it's getting there
yeah it's getting there but definitely
you know like talking about these things
feeling fun to go back to that point
super important because like rogue
legacy I respected the hell out of that
game but I hated getting like bad
genetics yeah like different characters
and I would stop playing at any points
and that's kind of the cipa thing here
you might run into playthroughs where
mice a playthrough but it could be like
five minutes it could be three hours but
you run into parts where you might not
find the blood sword or the dual daggers
or the ice blast or the bear trap you
see down here this I'm gonna keep
playing this this is kind of what I'm
playing right now and I really like it
it is on Steam early access I believe it
to $20 from that mistaken yeah if you
want to go check it out I highly
encourage people to even if that's not
your type of game it's worth checking
out and you can go play that as a now I
think was sixteen dollars
sixteen will sail hmm I don't think
there's a full release date but again
you might not even know it's early
access if you if you just want to get in
play now another kind of not small game
but like confine tight tightly designed
game is next machina which you played
you stream with Jake that's like playing
yeah it's a house mark am I saying that
right
they made a resogun which was a is it
house mark yeah okay
I love resogun yeah launch title for the
PlayStation 4 that was my playstation 4
was like aside from call duty ghosts'
was just resogun for about to watch game
for the system yeah it was really good I
played a lot of rows again cuz it was
what nack I don't want to watch on that
path did we talk about neck Idol or just
like no I just ever again I don't um
dark times yeah
but Reza if you played resogun which is
very much like defender yeah kind of and
then you were saying next machina is
like Robotron Robotron which was a
Genesis game no as an arcade original
now it was ported to other stuff it was
sort of the I don't want to see the
original twin-stick shooter but
essentially like one of the earliest
very popular twin-stick shooters
oh sorry one more thing about dead cells
Ronnie SC and the YouTube chat was
saying the price is the early access
price is 16 what that the for release
dead cells be 20 I said that makes sense
okay um but yeah next machina i yeah
twin-stick shooter pretty frantic as you
can see from this gameplay right here
this is not even the least of how crazy
it gets but the music is fantastic music
is energetic like driving kind of it's
half the soundtrack spirit angers yeah
oh and this wasn't say o Bhima Tron or
beam Tron excuse me this is a I'm here
you're adding letter so what are you
what do you call the iconic settlement
in Zelda what do you call Kakariko
village nevermind he calls it karaoke
village hey have fun sorry that's
mocking you I have not gotten to be
intron I've not I placed first boss my I
played the game for about an hour if
that I was using Jake's account on my PC
here umm did dude yeah we had a blast
with this game this is this is something
to look forward to honestly we had a
really fun time they like though yeah
the weapon types are great but it's it
looks I don't know we looks really
intimidating as far as the pacing and
like how much is going on but you are
very much in control and you are
consistently having these like
heart-stopping moments of just near
misses with like maybe those like orbs
or like there's one part in the stream
where was a giant boulder chasing us and
it was like I just member Jake being
like no way you're gonna make it it's
Raiders of the Lost Ark style just
screaming this is like it's it's just
like Rezo but you get into these tight
corners like there's no way I'm making
this out but then you use that uh
there's a - ability you correct three
charges before it recharges right yeah
can well yet it's there's a um there are
pickups you get and that's one of the
buildings yeah it's a three - yeah you
have one - which operates on cooldown
obviously but when you have three dashes
yeah you can chain three of them and you
get things like explosive - where you uh
you leave and explode when you land from
the - you leave in a explosion
but like we got to the last boss and the
thing about this game that the last boss
on the game last boss of this three
world demo okay cuz this is a beta a
beta is it public um closed it's closed
uh but oh my god the last we're playing
on easier and normally uh normal and we
couldn't finish it and we tried then
seeing what hard was like and hard oh my
god it's every like you start the game I
think the first enemy types don't have
any kind of projectile and I think that
every enemy has a projectile of like a
wave of those orbs is and it's like it
feels like the speed is cranked up like
double it's unreal on hardmode
which is a type of game you'd like to
see you know done like speed runs or
what-have-you the streaming I don't know
it this game is something look forward
to yeah again the music is spectacular
it's one of these games where you just
need to kind of try it to really
understand like the the feel of it I'd
it just doesn't look I mean it looks
cool but I think the the joy of just
getting out of these dire situations
like you eventually will have just like
tons and tons of enemies chasing you and
all your yeah it's it is stressful time
I'm stressed I don't even I was gonna
say it's very oddly therapeutic for me
yeah because you get into this kind of
flow state that just you can kind of as
fun it was funny watching you two on the
stream because you know you like I'm
watching you and you're like I don't
know how they're talking right now I
think Jake's playing right now but you
do get into this just trance and like
when I'm playing I'll play at lunch
sometimes for maybe 10 minutes and I
just it actually relaxes me in a weird
way yeah but it is it can get stressful
it kind of reminds me of like I don't
know cleaning your room yeah where it's
like you got all this probs mess on the
on the screen you gotta get rid of it
it's like just gratifying blow it all up
let's pick it up if they ever low up my
room to clean it yeah if you go to a
steam in like three months the house
mark is gonna put that pullquote
on the games page like cleaning your
room
Rob handler from GameSpot damn I haven't
seen some of these enemies those so
stacked razor blade things remind me of
the what's that enemy and Mario called
they're like those stacked spike balls
that you see in the desert area oh there
are like I accept these when you when
you destroy them they split up into
multiple those guys they'll split into
those things and leave like
ray'll of orb yeah death even watching
this is I know I'm so straight yeah but
it's when these things - were like the
ending boss right like we we got really
close to beating him and one of the
things we realized was like you want
that triple - because the ending boss is
is shooting out so many orbs at such a
high rate velocity that like you just
are constantly in need of a - and then
if we have that here's like a weapon
upgrade you can get you know - doubled
and triple here it's just yeah it's just
when you get those pickups it's just fun
and the other aspect of this is that
you'll see like humans they're the green
dudes there are in each little stage
here there are you know four to three
humans you want to save and that will
increase your score and if you are going
to be one of those guys trying to get on
the leaderboards that's crucial you pick
those and save them and they're because
they're getting you have a certain
amount of time because they're getting
like converted into into these alien
machines - and pray right uh yeah it is
very much you know like house mark with
resogun proved they could take this very
somewhat simple idea and make it a very
tight game that's why I'm excited for
this Jake went to PAX East and then came
back like would not stop talking about
this game oh for sure
I've never had someone in this office I
was I've never had someone in office
come in and like Jake of all people this
was like a really charming guy just
comes in he's like you are playing this
and he said that to beat you because
like I'm gonna make you play like shoot
you out of your own seat and he's
installing the game like you're going at
it was one of those points in the year
where what this was March being PAX East
yeah early March so there's what like
everybody here has been playing like 12
games here they're all fantastic as the
last thing I needed was another game and
he's like well it's already installed on
your PC so play it was alright and I'm
good recommendation yeah should again
this is a closed beta people in the chat
were saying they're winning for their
keys so I don't maybe they're sending
more out is there I don't know but this
will release in June
right around III I think or right after
you dreaming to xx so right after the
week after e3 or something like that so
this will be a good Playstation 4 and PC
game to play no longer just a
Playstation because I resogun was just
PlayStation 4 exclusive I believe it
still is right I don't think it ever
came there was also a Vita port ok um
yeah I also some PC I also want to
recommend you know you can't hear the
music here but if anyone who is just
curious about this game go check out
their trailer they have like a really
awesome like hand-drawn cinematic
trailer which is just blasting this like
house like retro synth music Nexus is
housemarque Swedish they're from there I
think they're from you know they're a
European developer but just when you
said house it reminded me of like
Swedish house house music that's where
house music started right sweetener this
is Sweden isn't a Vita Navi cheese
Italian that's not house music either
I'm sorry I'm butchering this whole
conversation no order I want I'm on like
episode 5 of master of none season 2 you
should watch it
yeah watch measure number on the whole
date does it mean well like well isn't
it like a transitional thing like that
oh yeah
anyway play what the [ __ ] are we talking
play next month
sorry hey Blaine ex machina when you get
a chance June 20th that is $20 uh from
house mark the developer of resogun if
you play like that game you'll probably
be super interested in this game it's in
closed beta right now but yeah like Rob
said go check out our gameplay on
GameSpot you can hear the music you
gotta hear the music also there is local
co-op
really yeah the beta right now no we
weren't able to develop it wasn't
implementing it implemented yet as far
as what we played but it is coming - uh
what ps4 and PC mm-hmm yeah we've been
playing on PC naught X naught Xbox know
okay um and V down assuming that maybe
you won't be able to cross play anything
on Vita PlayStation for now all you know
Zeebo says that house music started in
Detroit it's our Detroit d'etat
something good came
bill gates in a room just kidding I'm
just kidding
sorry if you're in Detroit I don't have
anything against Detroit so what this is
Eric eaves the other day in the chat you
see that what someone's out there at a
gaming tournament Syracuse the other day
yes I saw though I think I can't tell if
they're mocking me I'm from Syracuse New
York but anyway uh you have been playing
some Perron switch yeah who ever used a
show us bangers every times thumper is
said Peter just look to you and it's
getting scary as a pupil just dilate
show us the stance you said you were in
when you were laying in your couch the
other day play I was just by myself my
girlfriend's in another room and she
came back and I realized that I became
like self-aware and I was like just just
out of it just in it yeah it's like that
straight the 90s trailer
yeah it's don't like yeah so is thumper
better on switch all right I mean is it
a really good switch experience yes
it's best in VR but I'd say if you were
gonna have the choice between playing it
like on a TV or on switch
I recommend switch the stick on the the
controller of the switch like on the
body of it is not ideal necessarily but
the whole point of really getting into
this game and really seeing what it's
made of is to just let yourself go and
be a part of it because one it's so fast
but two it's it's all about atmosphere
as well is this actually this looks sped
up even for thumper oh no this is slow
for thumper what Oh mine is slow what
stage is this this is probably slow okay
no no this is where I probably don't
know this is like it's like Stage five I
think there's nine all those goddamn
things II's yeah yeah so yeah so that I
mean the one criticism you could levy
this game is that the as the world's
expand they kind of just like
reintroduce like little elements like
this yeah at different speeds with
slightly altered music but it's not
necessarily like a huge problem because
this game just I just like when I was
playing on PlayStation VR I would play
for like an hour straight and like take
my headset off and see everyone around
me like you know answering email
cracking a joke
it was like why would I ever do anything
but play thumper in VR I'm going back so
it's like the beginning of 28 days later
you're just Cillian Murphy coming out of
his sorry Killian Murphy coming out of
his coma his name is pronounced Killian
yeah and people we were talking about 23
Slayer on dead air this podcast we used
to have here about horror games and
movies and people got mad at me for
calling him Cillian I thought his name
was silly and anyway yeah but yeah
anywho I like here well look at this
footage I'm sorry Callie go ahead I was
just gonna ask so you talked about it
being great on in VR so is switch like
what's good so I'm saying switch is
better cuz you can hold it in front of
your face and like really get into and
yeah and just really get into it um I I
felt like what when I was holding it I
was more like we're saying Peter like I
found myself again bringing it closer
and closer to my face but when I hooked
it up you know did the switch if you
will to a TV and I had a better I feel
like I had a better experience along
with the the pro controller like I felt
the joy cons the the book the main bun
you're using really you're like pressing
it down so often it was like creating
that divot or pressure point bomb and
like stressing out my hand in general
you're feeling it I was feeling Y was
also playing for like three hours
straight I feel like I got a lot of
drugs just out on thumper its dude it's
it's a rock god yeah just like this is
what I look like majora for a second
this game is just insane I like got to
Stage five and they they're consistently
introducing more like obstacles and
that's why I want to say Peters those
rings that you see above you can hit
those for a higher score but like for me
I guess what I'm realizing is just
watching your footage and click uh I'm
assuming this is you is you're just
ignoring them right like you have to at
some point unless you're like insanely
good IV from PlayStation VR VR this is a
PlayStation VR foot job joining on a
thumper but joining the check yeah it's
just it's just so quick and so intense
that like I don't know at some point I
had to put it down I will come back to
it cuz it's really fun yeah those saw
those gates in the air get complicated
because if you get hung up on
trying to get a high score when you're
literally just trying to finish a level
which is hard enough on its own it's so
easy to just like run into a wall at
this speed and totally miss an
opportunity and especially in a boss
fight because you have to do these
segments perfectly if you write this one
right here do you miss one ketone you'll
have to restart that section over again
so those gates are optional so that's
probably why I was avoiding them but
yeah I mean I'd love to see like you
know the top players in the world like
how they yeah stuff at this speed so
this is out on switch now yeah what's
the easiest way to get it just through
the shop in shop yeah a ship issue it's
the only way to get it on switch shop
sweet so now it's on PlayStation 4 PS VR
and switch PC as well PC as well
Peter Christopher is your million
Christopher yes PC Brown
yes PCB PCP yep I would have been if I
was a girl apparently my name would have
been Pamela Christine because and
they've backed this up many times my
parents wanted my first two initials to
be PC because they're nerds
really I don't I but to me it's like
printed circuit board that's the real
nerdy acronym going on that's why you
own it as you ever handle like I like em
what wait sorry put a circuit board
what's a B what is a printed circuit
board it's a circuit board it's a
technical name for a circuit board but
printed yes you print circuits now Jesus
Mike I don't have all day to teach you
about electronic circuits has come to
town cool so thumper is a valve on
switch that the eShop if you want to go
play it there it's also available still
on PlayStation VR PlayStation 4 and PC
you can go check it out do it sound
effects this game I like I have that one
haunting one restart goes Tech game as
well is kind of hard to get a full
experience of just watching gameplay if
you haven't played that or an ex machina
there's both obviously thumpers very
reliant on its soundtrack as a rhythm
game be a go oh my god we go a pretty
Ellington on twitch chat so chemically
supports an electrically connects
electronic components using conductive
tracks pads and other features etched
from copper sheets laminate onto a non
conductive substrate
components for example capacitors
sisters or active devices are generally
soldered on the Peter Christopher Brown
it would I say soldered no sorry
Sauron I'll try to read it before it let
me chat thank you
I'm giving you a hard time now they're
talking about PCP hey if you have PCP or
in it yeah a couple hours in a bumper
and you'll have it they have buns native
done studies it's burst yeah you don't
need drugs to have fun you just a couple
hours you're just there's someone in a
lab somewhere making bumper copies with
beakers and chemicals alright um what
well o rhyme do we want to talk about
rhyme or we want to wait till next week
after reviews come out uh we could talk
a little bit about it your are you gonna
compare it to Zelda like you always do
now some in the chat said that earlier
before the show started up Pete compares
everything to Zelda I haven't but I will
now thump or anything like Zelda spite
actually hey you just fight Ganon at the
end to the Hyrule theme song it's a
beetle and there's beetles and yes yeah
that I named beetle there's a guy yeah
he loves beetles he'd probably love
thumper boom you want to know something
that makes me sound dumb and I probably
shouldn't announce it to the public I
did not get the whole Beatles pun until
I was like 15 oh really
yeah I've always been like a do a good
at spelling and I love the Beatles but
then I looked at it one day I'm like oh
[ __ ] that's beat like the beep anyway
it's ok it took me a while to get Flight
of the Conchords so well Sean McGinn is
a former GameSpot editor man get I guess
was seeing someone here was saying that
they talked to him he only just like a
few months ago got the South Park
fractured but whole please know I can't
believe that now I've heard that too yes
I don't know yeah well really is that
more unbelievable than me not knowing
the Beatles pun I guess so yeah well
we're on the news I hold you to a
different standard it's a little more on
the but um rhyme I guess it comes out
Friday do we want to talk about like
what it is just so people they're
probably seen a little bit of it but
it's an adventure game just like Zelda
okay it was a heard it here first
it was initially announced as a
PlayStation 4 exclusive at Gamescom 2013
I think from tequila works and it's kind
of been shaken up a little bit
it has almost a winwaker like aesthetic
and essentially what we are getting is
an adventure game where you are
exploring an island with very little
direction and you were to started using
the cues around you to solve puzzles and
for where to go and yeah it the art
style also sort of reminds me of the
witness that might also be the island so
yeah hmm hmm but I don't know I'm drawn
to the art style it surrounding me of
the Last Guardian got the gameplay in
the hooded figure it looks like journey
yeah you have this little um what other
games do we see in this yeah you have a
little animal companion that's like a
fox which is probably better than bird
dog because it's a more manageable size
in my opinion cool uh Oscar Deus in the
UK our UK office will be reviewing err
he is reviewing it yourself to do this
tomorrow
philosophers Oscar de sus contagious
wrong with me I hope he's watching right
now
I hope he's taking a break from
reviewing this game so wash Kali lost it
oh my god hang a little is ruined er I
love you asked I could keep going things
I know most of that oh my god uh uh yeah
Ryan will be out Friday our review will
be up tomorrow what time 8:00 in the
a.m. Pacific M stands for morning 8:00
a.m. Pacific time you can go check out
Oscar Deus his thoughts can't say his
name though thinking about that I yeah
I'll be up go maybe check it out I don't
his review will be done tomorrow uh what
else we have to talk about oh we finally
got into battlegrounds game like
everybody seems to be talking about and
now I kind of get why I'm loving it and
I suck at it perhaps player unknowns
battleground if you played uh it was
originally like a Hunger Games mod for
ARMA 3 I believe little like that the
concept there wasn't called Hunger Games
if they've done to give me that look I'm
not telling Rob right efficient
returned to this plane of existence yet
so the last person to talk to ARMA 3
about I don't know it was originally mob
but now it's a full game and just what
was it pre its early access but the
sales from it were just like monumental
yeah they would like came out of the
gate really strongly but it's it's I
don't even know how to describe it it's
a very hardcore kind of third-person
military shooter but is you've like seen
the Hunger Games or need to go farther
back Battle Royale
I remember that parachuting scene it's a
five by five island that you essentially
you are you can go solo or you can go as
on teams but you start with a hundred
people and you just want to be the last
one surviving here's a gameplay from
Dave and Lucy over in our UK office you
get down you have to gather supplies and
guns and then the play area that you are
supposed to be fighting in will slowly
restrict so by the end of the match I
think the best I've done is I was the
15th person person alive is that the
right way to say that I was the 15th I
was one of 15 survivors and then I got
killed because the play area got
shrunken so much and I actually got
lucky I landed somewhat in the middle of
what would eventually become the zone
because if you're outside of that you'll
start slowly losing health oh timorous
playing this this maybe this is for
player team over at McKee office yeah
yeah I have yet to play the team mode
but yeah it's it's pretty intense
hearing someone come into the you know
that's what everyone says right it's
like you're in a house and you hear
someone come in it's a what's my next
move well yeah
oh it's terrifying going into a house
yeah but the best workers and what my
best playthrough I guess you'd call it I
was on the third floor of this house I
was doing a solo and uh I've just found
this house like I said pretty semi close
to what would eventually become like the
zone that was fighting in but I was on
the third floor in this attic and the
sound design his games phenomenal so you
could hear on the floorboards downstairs
two floors down someone coming in and
then you'd hear a car drive up outside
be like oh my god yeah you can get
vehicles when people are playing on
teams you can have these like kind of
squads of dune buggies but yeah I was on
the third floor and I had a shotgun and
all of a sudden this guy came up I
killed him and he dropped his
Lieut so I got a scar assault rifle I
got a handgun
I got like bulletproof vest or you know
like a in a backpack with more inventory
I picked that up and then I ran up a
hill and the guy killed me is it better
with like a team of people you know I
like even more solo I think it is it is
very fun co-op I've played maybe three
matches with other people but I myself I
like the tension of playing alone but
Rob you were saying you like I well
having seen a lot of twitch streams and
stuff of the team centered moments it
seemed to be in my opinion just be a lot
of fun like I generally saw like a lot
more crazy like or funny moments you
know what these two guys were in I think
this is one of the highlight reels of
guy who does a Kotaku or yeah Kotaku
yeah yeah these two guys who would seem
to be like 10 minutes waited in a Jeep
that they had gotten into a corner of
the hall of the middle and they're just
like and they just are waiting for like
10 minutes cuz you can hear people
opening doors like rhyming it so finally
two guys at the end of the hall come
into the room and then they just got it
billowing down this hallway that with
the other two people had of course like
no idea that was gonna happen they just
crush him against the wall and melee to
start laughing those moments seem really
fun but as well as the more serious
stuff we're like tactics we're like you
know you you don't die immediately when
you when you get killed you're down and
you get revived so you're talking to
your buddy like he's over here he's over
here and you just he was a giant bump
thing and then just one came around the
corner it just shotgun yeah guy in the
face yours like that is Jeff is like
that was awesome uh so you really want
to see I I know when I was playing solo
and having not play this game you know
obviously you get better over time but
like I just an instinct you know what no
I love the chairs you just instinctively
really want to to have a buddy to to
help you out I don't know and I feel
like you can get longer or farther into
a game opposed to dying immediately it's
like you have more of a chance so the
biggest like barrier to entry for me for
games like this is like learning curves
I hate like letting people down
and so that's like kind of what has been
stopping me from playing play solo for a
while I would recommend solo is a good
way to get into it that's that's my
preferred way but yeah that's the thing
is I just whenever it's an online thing
I get so nervous because I'm like I
don't want to let anybody down but also
I have no idea what I'm doing is I just
started playing this game yeah um and so
I just like getting over that like if
it's easy to get over that learning
curve then that's great yeah I think so
I mean it's you know it's no different
like what we were playing recently right
with like za or it is different but you
know similar in as far as like nazi
zombies right like yeah I don't know you
that was different cuz I played that
game before and I'm sure jump in with
you guys
sure yeah just I know I I do really want
to play more of this and uh get good
this game is definitely intimidating but
like yeah you do have to be very
tactical people in the chat we're saying
this is like one of those shooters where
you can't be pissed that someone's
camping that's like this game right so
Stacey
so say you land you parachute under the
east side of the island you don't know
where the battle zones gonna eventually
be confined to you can get lucky
sometimes like I didn't I was in the
Attic for the whole time until I had to
go up this hill and someone you know the
best players will look at where the
massive zone starts and kind of see
where the center is going to be so then
they will go there in camp and they're
already in position like the best
players will get supplies realize that
they have enough and then just wait
there
even when I'm going across fields I'll
go prone and just you know like military
crawl or whatever you wanna call it
across the field because it's it's
terrifying it's exhilarating once I
realize like I should I have to leave
this house now
there's 18 people left aside from me I
can hear gunshots kind of close by it
gets really scary yeah it's it's a very
different experience playing co-op it's
very fun it is uh you definitely start
to have to rely on your teammates kind
of especially we're going to clear a
house yeah and it gets to the point
where you know there's 18 people left
and the zone is tiny you're like there
are guaranteed people in this house and
when you go and clear it out it's pretty
terrifying but yeah people just joining
asking this player unknown battlegrounds
um I really like this game it is just
kind of a gold mine for like you were
saying like highlight kind of stuff i
Daniel Dwyer has been doing a lot of his
yeah very funny there is another scene
as those
bombs drop was another one we're like
these two guys are in a house and
they're and just talking to each other
and just like it's going on right but
they think they're safe with the roof
over their head and the guys like have
you ever like died like in a house from
like one of these things he's like no
never
immediately yeah shell drops and kills
them both it's like yeah I don't know I
lately I I really want to play more
games with like friends and stuff
there's this you can just make anything
like we'll get to it later or maybe this
perfect segue is a Fri a thirteenth lab
we've been playing here and it is yeah
yeah um we've been having a blast
playing that game uh oh I have at least
chatting with people but I kind of did
not I did not like it at all no uh that
is people are super interested in it
yeah people love horror right you're
reviewing it right yes
reviewing progress is up on site right
now I give it a not scored yet out of
ten yeah it's uh I'll wait until we
switch footage well yeah yeah for people
who don't know Friday the 13th is a like
one called asymmetrical multiplayer game
yes um I guess it's nothing like it but
you want to go back to maybe like left 4
dead or no sorry evolved one person
versus four in this case it is Jason
Voorhees versus four of the Camp Crystal
Lake teenagers if you get more familiar
with those sponge camp counseling the
Friday the 13th movies it comes out
Friday
but we've been people in our office
about playing the last couple days so
incredibly boring I was so bored yeah I
mean like so Peter you touched on this
in your review like when you first start
playing if you die early like if you're
a counselor and you die early you could
be waiting for like 15 minutes and just
spectating yeah um and that's boring but
also like I just I didn't actually like
the the task of trying to escape and
protect myself like just kind of you
know running through this camp and I
just was so bored like I just kind of
like hung out in the closet and waited
for you to come kill me Peter was like
Jason like six times and sorry Peter you
go ahead I was going to say that totally
valid like that I survived a few matches
by playing a stealthy character and just
camping in a tent which wow that's the
perfect use of that
Fraze uh but uh you know it's one of
those scenarios where it's like all
right well so what's what's the point of
playing is the point of playing just to
amass experience points and not die or
is it to try to like to get crafty you
know and avoid death at the hands of
this dude who has crazy advantages I
think you have to be you have to go into
this looking for that kind of experience
where you know the odds are stacked
against you and you're going to have to
scrounge and be stealthy essentially do
things that are kind of stressful and
will make you you know worried moment to
moment or you could just do this right
but I just don't feel like there's
enough I don't feel like there's enough
to the the movement in the act of
scrounging around making compelling so
it's like oh I find a flare gun I can
only carry one thing which is like fine
that could be interesting but I just
feel like it's something with the
movement or something I guess I use of
there's not enough there for me it's
just a really bad job of explaining the
the different options you have available
to you so the whole point is there's a
fixed amount of time the counselors
either have to survive before Jason
kills them for the clock runs out or
find a way to escape the camp and
escaping the camp means finding items to
fix vehicles but that's never really
explained to you and you're not going to
just sort of figure that out maybe you
could but but but immediately you just
know that you need to hide right so your
first thought is not going to be like I
need to find a car and see what parts I
need and those and there are your
objectives that's the only time it like
explains other than the intro like how
to play but like despite this info being
given you're right like as far as you've
no idea where the stuff is or how to
find it yeah I mean you have to go
through a lot of matches that are boring
or you die a lot right to get to the
point where you you kind of understand
the lay of the land is that worth it
like what's compelling meat I don't mean
to be like antagonistic and it was like
no I I have so many other games to play
and like just things that I want to do
why should I have to go through all
these boring matches where I mean like
we got kicked so many times yeah
yesterday trying just to play yeah where
I was like I why would I put up with
this when I could be doing literally
anything else no well and and that's the
other valid point is that we had a lot
of connection problems yeah yeah we were
getting here for matches all the time
and it was making it kind of
Australian to get to match and I think
Kelly you make an excellent point
you know it's what did it for and that's
all I can really explain is what did it
for me because I was definitely like put
out for my first few matches as
councillor but once I got to play as
Jason I kind of understood the dynamic
between the two sides a little bit
better and maybe I could see the
mistakes that I had been making through
the eyes of Jason which which then led
me to think about the game differently
when I was a counselor yeah that's fair
that's that's interesting to me like
that's the only thing that has hooked me
is hearing that from you that's the only
reason I would want to try to keep
playing the viola and and and this was
where I was mentioning earlier is like
and where for me it got interesting was
when like Peter and I last night a
couple of other people in the office
which played late and we were actually
finally talking with other people and
chatting yeah unlike what we do I have
the gas tank come to me and this is
footage of my play like towards the end
last night was the first time as
councilor I won and it was a pretty
funny story where Nick margarita what
was playing and this one this woman over
here was like she got the battery she
brought the car and then I had Reina
stamina so I'm from a hilltop I'm
looking down in Jason's killing her but
she got the battery to the car engine
and died I'm like no crap muck on there
and I met up with two other people we
had a gas tank they had the keys we're
putting the gas tank or point gas into
the car doing a little mini game and if
you fail the mini game or are stalling
the mini game then Jason like hears you
so I was pretty awesome I did like a
flawless gas tank filled yes I'm hella
good this is me by the way I am keeps
character I did I did you mocap and that
is a my own cardigans so here's that
this is actual footage of it but um the
thing was I was I getting out I'm sorry
later huh all this let's play out but so
as I'm doing this yeah that you you were
covering your buddies that's Nick
Margaery there with the plaid with a
flare job
and so the male host Nick didn't know
how to play so the fight it was then
like Nick runs over the front and he
gets a battery and he starts hooking it
up and right now you you're slowly
hearing the Jason music bill because he
is getting closer and closer so it's
making that minigame very stressful so
I'm here like I got the flare gun so
next to it and Nick is in the office
Nick's going damn it all I mean while
he's alerting Jason to know exactly
where we are and let it play out but the
point being is that this is a very
center door here comes so though Jason
is just here so now so by the way he's
coming so by way this is a two-seater
car so three of us Jason I assume in the
head where I love that the velvet wait
you didn't know who that person took the
car it's a nick who helps if you can't
tell us
this game isn't rough around the edges
but it's almost I mean do you guys play
dead by daylight earlier this year or
last year sorry um that game same idea
asymmetrical horror there were different
killers but that was the only way to
escape was to activate these Jenner
generators animals just said genitals on
accident you know my yeah well whatever
uh you had to activate generators to
escape this like whatever math they lay
down this there are more options
available and it's also more you know
like more focused on Friday 13th but it
seems like kind of almost in the same
vein of battlegrounds I think
battlegrounds more polished seems like
very much so especially getting into it
out of matches but seems rough around
the edges but they're like the emergent
situations like Nick margarita running
next to the car when yeah he did alt
like most of the world that's all
straight out of Jason
was it I wasn't here for that I had yeah
so that makes me want to try this game
again right experience something like
that I just my first impression was
really bad now and we were on the same
boat like we were all there but we
decided early car in the in the office
you shouted this is a dud I remember and
then it got better yeah we had a lot of
fun yesterday playing with randoms oh
right who were really antagonistic but
then we like got them to like come on
our side and like joke around with us
and then so rob was playing as Jason and
the whole point was that we were like
just gonna just be friends we work at it
no one's gonna try to kill anyone we
were going to go around the campfire and
but be mom tell Robin like alright did
you can kill them but just don't kill me
it's so like like slowly one by one he
starts killing people and then we like
run off and I find you and you just like
murder me and it and it was like this
just comedic scenario in a game that's
meant to be horrifying and it just comes
down to the people playing it you know
like it's a it's a great thing for for
that I again expecting a lot just like
battlegrounds a lot of streams and like
like funny pranks like again like this
the same instance where I'm Jason I'm
still engaging Jen I'm like hey guys I'm
making a campfire we're gonna cook up
some chili and they all know your actual
jason voice that I heard for like three
hours yesterday was I sit next to Romney
ah oh you were doing he was doing like I
made chili
oh guys they made chili and then that is
I'm a shuttle animate guys boys just
severus yeah great a lot of characters
came out yesterday but they're all like
they all show up and they're all really
timid and I'm Jason at this campfire and
they're like are you sure you're not
ghosts I'm like I'm totally not gonna
kill you make some chili and then and
then we're all there and it's like what
do you actually do on my obviously can't
make chili in the game so we're standing
there I go I just go hey guys guess what
I go no I go hey guys guess what and one
of the shotgun goes shoots me and stuns
me I was like I look Alan it's blood
like so you're I would expect a lot of
again like streams and funny kind of
like viral stuff this game needs work
clearly he's a lot of work it needs a
lot of work around eyeballs or there's
no the animation
are so like they're really gentle
they're Jenkin it's it's funny is it's
on the level of like bad b-movie slasher
films I would say to an extent work you
could kind of it was on purpose I'm not
saying it was on purpose
I'm not saying was on purpose but why I
am saying is that it kind of makes it so
dumb and fun like in that respect seeing
that that character we just saw every
cutscene beginning he just turns around
it's the most like the most obnoxious
face uh yeah my how was the balance like
because my initial impression from
playing it a few months ago was that I
mean he's supposed to be but Jason was
very very overpowered and I guess that
fits all right so so part of it is right
like either just if you just sort of
like hide you're not gonna find things
like firecrackers or the flare gun or
stuff like that things that can actually
give you an advantage to get away from
Jason you can step bear traps there's a
lot of things you can do he is pretty
overpowered but part of the game is
managing as a counselor like how often
you move how rushed you are how much
fear you're giving off because those are
the sort of things that he senses and
there are also other characters right so
there's a girl I unlocked who has 10 out
of 10 stealth there was one time where I
was literally crouched in a room and
Jason just looking around and I couldn't
see me so you can find ways to get
around it you just have to like spend
enough time to understand that the tools
available to you okay how you unlock new
campers yeah oh one one annoying thing
that I overheard you guys saying is
unlike battlegrounds which you die a lot
in you can leave the match right away
once you die in this you have to wait
out the rest of the match to get
experience right that's you're saying oh
right you to talk about that okay
you can that sounds annoying as hell I'm
lead but you're gonna lose all or a good
this is this bermed right you're gonna
lose a good amount of your experience I
have a keen experience get added on yeah
believe in oh man so it's yeah one
experienced to unlock the better things
you have to like sticker I was like
answering emails and doing my makeup
yeah okay and you might as well because
I think you get at least 500 experience
points for finishing a match by just
waiting it out that's enough to roll a
random perk right so like you might as
well just do that so you can get a
random ability to tack on your
characters because you start with none
yeah and you know there is a chance
you'll be resurrected as a character
who's got like really high stats and a
shotgun but that's not guarantee that's
up to the players in the game to do
something to activate that it and weird
someone did kind of bring that up like
within the first beginning moments of
the game like Jason gets stronger and
stronger right yes so you know it did
maybe you could be that lone wanderer
and hide intent the whole time but it
could be detrimental in the end because
he can eventually just like find you
yeah that's true you're reviewing
progress will be up today man it huh it
is awesome
we're working on a video review to go
with that but the full review should be
next week sometime I got Tekken 7 in
inviting my time between Tekken 7 damn
her to 13th we got like what to arcade
cabinets for our office for Tekken 7
yeah we have an unboxing video of that
that Joe and I did Joey's our official
resident unboxer now is that absolute
video that's gonna be tomorrow okay um
tomorrow morning and then yeah and then
station Friday for a livestream where we
will put those things to the test in
terms of live streams also before we get
off Friday the 13th
what time 2:00 p.m. Pacific at all I'll
be playing with guys maybe you bought
you and Jake we streaming but I think
back in the office or like outside the
studio I think like Nick a few people
will be playing hop on yeah yeah yeah
this you want to watch that should be
pretty funny yeah we're going to this
morning we had some technical problems
but it will not happen again uh yeah so
come back later on today like 2:00 p.m.
after the lobby for to watch Friday the
13th Robin Jake will be streaming it but
everybody else in the office will be
playing we're also planning on streaming
it tomorrow
do we have a special guest maybe oh
there is a funny story behind that what
what that I have half an idea of what
you're saying well I thought we were
getting Adam Sessler to come in oh is
that happening Miguel's been planning
that right is that tomorrow maybe we'll
find out okay
so that's a half to use this isn't my
habits what's happened yeah I don't know
I haven't heard an update on that great
sorry everyone
ah well we're gonna do it twice word why
and then you guys have Dino DNA we can
talk more yeah
AVX penguins a Dino DNA fan uh yeah so
uh you can check that out later on uh
now I want to talk about destiny too
that was the big event last week Kelly
you are a big destiny fan yeah you know
it I play a good amount of destiny like
I said Jean Luc and Eric hey who are in
the backroom running the show right now
went down to LA last week to check out
destiny to play it on PC yeah they
played a date at a strike and John Luke
did Chris Paul yeah yeah there's a lot
of new information I'll kind of run
through a laundry list of those things
first and then we can kind of get some
impressions but they showed off the
trailer for those who don't know it's
the tower they're the last city is kind
of attacked by the Cabal they seem to be
the main antagonists in this as opposed
to what the fallen kind of were the
first one you run into in the first - II
yeah um um there's like a cabal leaders
name is like galore looks sort of like
Google um Kengo uh and um yeah it's like
the this is I think this might be I'm
not sure where we are in this section
cuz I this is at the tower right it's
being yeah so yeah you're defending the
tower at the beginning of Allah right
there next to evening yeah I am leader
yeah and so there's some returning
characters so obviously if you saw the
like initial trailer like Kade isn't it
and um I Cora Cora and Zavala and yeah
so we learned a lot about the game
actually yeah seems I think overall
takeaway you can fund in bungees words
I'm mark Noseworthy the producer we did
interview with him
I think they talked to a few people down
there but he was saying they do want to
make it accessible but not at the
detriment of its depth because they want
you know like now it's on it's going to
draw on a whole new audience on PC it is
on a battlenet so it's Blizzard
exclusive in terms of us yeah so that's
interesting the first time they've had
an on Blizzard game yeah I guess it
makes what guess it makes sort of sense
if that of all games would be this with
Activision's involvement honors right
but yeah there won't be cross play
obviously but or you know like people
are asking there wouldn't be PvP cross
play but people are asking if there
could be co-op but that'd just be a
whole cannibal I highly doubt it
I also don't know I'm so care like your
gear and stuff won't transfer but
apparently your character's appearance
transfer yes but I don't know how that
works on PC if you play it if you're if
you're planning to switch to PC and you
played on right a ps4 AIC hm I don't
know how like I don't know if you get
your character's appearance or if that's
just like if you played on xbox and you
get destiny too on xbox your character
appearance bulge wasn't there like a
weird like app you could use to like
manage your inventory yeah there's a
desk yes I love the destiny action maybe
that's just it maybe that's the link
maybe yes yes um but yeah this I mean
just this will really September 8th
there's no PC release a yep a ps4 Xbox
uh for DLC in the future it will be time
to exclusive for ps4 as with destiny 1
right it'll just be the most content
will come out on ps4 first and then xbox
later that is until at least fall 2018
according to Bundy yes so if you're on
PlayStation 4 you'll get to play the new
content a little bit earlier there's a
beta coming this summer if you preorder
the game apparently you can get access
to it a little sooner than the public
but yeah there's new four new planets
like worlds but in terms of the last
city being attacked you're going to be
going down to Earth's surface as your
home base if I'm not mistaken and like I
said it'll be a little more accessible
there are like some weapon things like
you have a there's chained guns and
grenade launchers there's a third weapon
instead of a secondary weapon it's so
they're energy changed the weapon
classes so it was primary secondary
heavy this now it's kinetic energy and
the last one is like a heavier it's like
a heavy but I forget what the kinetics
are more like conventional bullets
energy air yeah kinetic there's overlap
between kinetic and energy so you could
very likely have the same gun equipped
in the kinetic slot and the energy slot
and the heaviest stuff like grenade
launchers the chain gun and you know
like fusion rifles and stuff that would
be a heavy minigun right here you can
see on the other chain gun sorry uh this
is a still the same mission what appears
to be the first mission of the game out
assume the story mode or at least like
soon after the beginning I think it is
yeah um yeah and then in terms of the
classes the new subclasses for the
hunter warlock and Titan saw the dawn
blade Stryker and then was it still the
gun sling or no it's um
Hunter's staff right hunter one was uh
oh my gosh why am i blinking on the
character John work straighter arc
Strider thing got it right we said it
same time cool yeah so yeah you swing a
staff around and then there's the the
Titan ones like sort of Captain America
looking shield that you swing around and
then I never play warlock but it's a
flaming and now I want to because it's a
flaming sword that shoots fire so that's
pretty rad Oh power thank you the heavy
heavy replacement is power gotcha um
yeah so we had to see new supers and
subclasses from the reveal which was
cool just to give you idea of like
what's changing and what's new what do
you think about guided games this their
their attempt at trying to appease
people who want matchmaking I think but
it sounds a little better in my opinion
I don't think it's an attempt to appease
anybody I think it's really really smart
actually so guided games is basically
there's a official clan support so
before if you wanted to play like a raid
for instance you had to get six people
together um and if you didn't have six
friends who if you didn't have six
friends you were screwed and if you
didn't have you couldn't get everybody
online at the same time then it was
really hard to do anything this has
official in-game clan support and
basically guided games is when like a
clan if you have like five people who
are ready to play you're looking for a
sixth you can put like a clan
description and somebody who's a solo
player can search clans who are looking
for a solo player and kind of pick who
they want to play with based on what the
clans description is so it kind of gives
you more control over the types of
people you're playing with and so your
sixth won't just be this it won't be
some that that wants to screw things up
right like if you're trying to complete
the raid someone just comes in and just
just destroys like everything and ruins
your time and yeah then that's no fun
and so it gives you more control and I
like that like I said we were talking
bout battlegrounds like I get really
nervous about letting people down if I'm
playing something co-op and I just like
that you can kind of go in and see like
oh this clan is like hey we're gonna
teach new players how to do the raid
we've done the raid a couple times and
people can be really welcoming or if
it's like hey we're looking for someone
who knows what the hell they're doing
join our group and we'll raid do we know
how they'll communicate what they're
looking for are there like set like play
styles and a lot of games
say like competitive or feedback I'm not
sure the during the presentation they
had like clan names my favorite was
every rose has Hawthorne where they were
and I thought that was really good I
loved it and like a description of what
the clan is and like so they had an
example of like scrolling past one that
was like weed pone noobs or whatever and
they were like reject um so I'm not sure
if it's like manually in put did okay
yeah I'm really excited about that I
think that's a really smart solution for
especially like the the endgame higher
level content like the raid yeah um yeah
they're trying to open up stuff and then
night falls won't and I thought yeah
that'll also be can't you just play it
other if you want to you do is there
still a level cap for those I thought
they said something about like night
falls being open to everyone um they
wanted it they said something about it
just stuff being more accessible to all
players which was part of the guided
game's philosophy um I assume it would
still have a cap um but I'm I'm yeah
sure if they said explicitly what about
a they said there would be more than
just patrols on the surface and the
planet now so exploration is greatly
expanded so before like if you wanted to
go down to you know the cosmodrome you
would do patrols and that's basically
what you could do and it got very stale
after a while they're promising more
open exploration so like actual bona
fide towns and you can there's like side
quests the NPC's will give you so like
actual NPC side quest givers instead of
picking up a Patrol yeah NPC's sense
like a much-needed thing absolutely for
the world like outside of my um the one
they showed looked like he honestly
looked like a kind of what am I thinking
for like Saving Private Ryan he was in a
tower with a sniper rifle but he looked
he was actual like look from another
game honestly it didn't look sci-fi he
looked like he was dressed like World
War two kind of clothing like a survivor
on the Earth's surface
yeah they had earth towns that looked
very like um they were like shanty towns
kind of yeah um and I like that a lot I
like that they have they're kind of
fleshing out the world because a lot of
the world building in destiny was in
grimoire and if you didn't care about
that or didn't read that I usually just
read it on the app when I wasn't playing
when I was like in my height well
written obsessed and cool stuff too it's
a shame that they I don't know they
didn't have more of that in the game
yeah
so I'm hoping that that means their
point they're going to I mean that's
another side of the accessibility coin
um is just making the actual world more
apparent the actual story and background
I think that's more enjoyable then if
for the hardcore player who's going to
like try to get grimoire and read it in
their spare time
right um yeah we would one of those
things call they said there are those
gonna be these like side missions
adventure adventures yeah it was about
yeah so that is like a treasure hunt I
think that was one of the examples but
they specifically described this
treasure hunting where you have like an
actual map and you go to forget what
it's called but you go to like an area
specifically designed for the side quest
and you have to fight a boss and the
boss holds the key to a treasure chest
and there's like a loop in it
you think those will lead to exotics
ever that I would hope so I mean that
would be that would be a cool way to
like it just a different way to get to
exotics and legendary especially for
someone who's playing the game maybe
solo and wants to come in and kind of
just for the exploration rather than the
actual you know like Eric's a super into
mid maxing and right now getting the
most out of what he can from you know my
falls and radius and whatnot it would
absolutely be nice to like because when
I was grinding a lot for a rise of iron
like I just had to do the same strikes
over and over again um because I didn't
want to do that there's like one way
that was like mid maxing and I just
didn't feel like doing it and so I liked
that with the side quests and the
exploration there's a potential for a
little more variety and how you get more
gear it's not clear if that's actually
how it'll work but that's what it seems
like Peter and Rob as two people Craig
went wrong who weren't traditionally
into the first destiny does this excite
you from what you've seen or is it doing
enough to get you invested at all I
wanted to get into destiny after like
the first year once things started
changing for the better but I think but
I yeah but I felt like I had kind of
missed the boat already totally so I'm
interested you know this time around
because it's we're all going to be
uneven footing I feel like yeah and I
get to be a part of that hype cycle that
kind of is important you know the social
aspect of a game like this means
something yeah it's I love that and I
also I mean I just love how the shooting
feels in this game like I I'm just
really excited to
have a better version of that honestly I
know a lot of people are like it's
destiny 1.5 but if they just take what
was good about the first destiny and
round it out then then I'm hopeful about
it yeah I think tey had a good line
which was like yeah like regarding the
1.5 comments you see like everywhere uh
he did basically like think like think
about Cod like they don't really release
something on the first few Cod's like
that never really went too far away from
like the norm they've set right like
this is this is the series of destiny I
don't know like I makes it how they put
it was obviously better than more
eloquent than me like I just understood
great what works yeah exactly
funny if they I mean Bungie from the
beginning when they first announced
destiny before we really knew what it
was but how many years ago now five I
think they were saying it's more of a
platform than a game that's why like
yeah there's always you know like taking
King obviously revamped the foundational
a few foundational you know like systems
that place before that but I do have
John Luke actually um I did want to pull
up some questions because those might
lead to some yeah some other things that
I haven't really uh we're already gone
from them I was going to talk about
multiplayer for a hot second I don't
know the crucible yet only four before
or before so they're just like
tightening up the multiplayer modes okay
some of the modes from destiny might be
changed or not returned so there's no
free-for-all just as an hour just just
said we're four before okay interesting
um I do have some questions John Luke I
think we got it in from Twitter
yesterday when I I asked for questions a
few people from our community
here we go ray he goes even if destiny
to is amazing how does it feel that I
could take another 1700 hours of your
life are people up for that again those
video games baby yeah yeah this is what
we do ah I would though to go a little
farther I would like like you were
saying I would like more reason to
return outside of the grind
absolutely I don't want to keep doing
the same strikes I would love to come
back one day and maybe explore I about
to come back the next day play like a
raid with Eric hey and you and John Luke
the next day maybe come in and play some
crucible I would not like to do the same
six strikes over and over and over
yeah like even if you're like if I think
it's Tuesday when stuff refry or
whatever day it is yeah
um like have I liked that schedule like
that's something that the community
really likes a lot of people are like
alright Tuesday we're getting together I
didn't really do a whole lot of that
because I was like I got stuff to do um
so I don't know what day it is actually
but um I would I would definitely like
more than just like an obligation to
come back I think that's what destiny
needs right uh yeah ray on Twitter thank
you very much for your question I
believe we have two more jean-luc
correct me if I'm wrong but here we go
hex Tigran hexade Hren do you think
destiny two might try to appeal the
players you're not enjoy destiny uh I
guess I gotta ask you you to that
already but uh yeah maybe the the guided
stuff could help yeah or or the more
exploration and NPCs like you seem to be
well yeah the story of that deadly yeah
I mean I remember uh from what I played
like you know but again part of it was
what Peter was saying which like I
missed the boat when like when I
whenever any kind of update happened new
raid I can't get there I can't hang out
with my buddies and play that [ __ ] I
have to do all this grind in order to
get there and that's just intimidation
which like I'll I'll wait you I was like
I was waiting and this might be Peter I
talked about like yeah this is now a
nice fresh start for those people who
may be dropped off but again one of
things I did notice was like in those
open area moments like when you're just
riding around there were only those
those events right or like just certain
you you felt like you were hitting the
same lanes you're doing the same kind of
routes hopefully that you can spawn in
different areas and see different
perspectives didn't like yeah different
like you know angles of this beautiful
world it is a gorgeous world but you're
always going from A to B and that's the
same like to know things like that and
NPCs and these kind of side quests seem
to be we're hopefully able to change
that that's exciting
cool so EXCI drin if I'm pronouncing it
correctly thank you for the clip the
question over Twitter I again I think we
have one more do you think lost sectors
will be an analog to horizons cauldrons
or more akin to the raid puzzles of
destiny one are those the adventures in
adventure area yeah um I think that it
seems like they'd be a little more in
depth in the cauldron of the cauldrons
from what I remember of horizon we're
pretty straightforward right you just
get it for my boss and then I
beautiful I don't think it'll be near I
wouldn't compare it to a raid puzzle
though like I mean it would be on a much
smaller scale right yeah anything might
size kind of as opposed yeah great
puzzles which could take hours to figure
out yeah you the first time you do the
raid is like okay what the hell are we
doing where where as I think this is I
mean this is intended to be done like
maybe you could have like one person
joint you just do like simple co-op or
by yourself I don't think it's that
scale so I don't know but also I don't
think the cauldron is would be work more
lease more indebted more involved in
that yeah grant willson thank you for
your question and I think that's all the
destiny two questions if you want more
destiny we have like a hub up on
GameSpot for all you need to know if you
play destiny want to know what's changed
you hadn't didn't get to catch up last
week or if you're new to destiny and
just want to kind of figure out what's
going on we have a lot of information up
gianlu can tell you had a lot of good
coverage they get big attack gameplay
they did they played on PC PC and we
have gameplay that I believe there's no
release date for no CC no we do not have
PC gameplay sorry they just they had
played in that they did play they've
hands-on oppression yeah apparently it
you know mouse keyboard like felt really
great if not better yeah and then we
have an article on everything you need
to know about the PC version and like
specs and and keyboard mapping and all
that stuff if you're a PC player you
know and that's things I would be really
interested in playing PC I guess I don't
know my guys first friends most people
gonna be playing on ps4 but yeah that's
bummer that that's not gonna be at
launch yeah September 8th for ps4 Xbox
one then you know like once we know P
series release date we will let you know
um I shall like I think I had one more
question that was kinda unrelated to
this in t2 if not then I could be wrong
a good Corey nope okay well actually I
remember it mark M he always asks a lot
of a he sends and stuff for the lobby a
lot um he was asking he said there's
been a lot of kind of under the radar
indie games this year that we might not
I guess dead cells would have been a
more apt question to ask this during or
more segments but he was asking kind of
like I don't know just to round out the
show you guys been playing lately that
might be under the radar or anything
like dead cells I guess would be
probably the best one to say but a night
the woods earlier this year
night I could not I didn't get to talk
about night in the woods that much but I
can
recommend that game enough it's
phenomenal it's this like multi-layered
look at Middle America and kind of like
working class struggle and struggles
with depression and exponential crisis
and you know the quarter life crisis I
mean it's just so phenomenally done I
love that game um and then one that I've
been seeing decent reviews for is an old
man's journey so I simplistic I've heard
good things work that I only kind of in
line with a I don't know it's more about
like platform not platform abut clicking
through this uh pretty gorgeous like
almost not hatin hand-painted world
maybe like watercolor ish I don't know
maybe check science we ever pay for it
no okay um yeah I want to check it out
at some point but uh yeah man mark M I
believe thanks for tweeting me yesterday
um yeah cool damn there's a long show
well we had a lot to talk about
yeah like I said at 2 p.m. Pacific will
be playing Friday 13th Jake and Rob will
be streaming it and then we'll be
playing back in the office Dino DNA the
new dinosaur live stream from the we'll
be playing and then the mosquito landed
on the tree and got stuck in the Sam
they played Telltale's Jurassic Park
game last week from what I saw so you
don't have to yeah we made a mistake we
made a mistake
we had fun there's a cool moment where I
want to go where they're gonna let that
little girl die there's a there's a girl
character and you know you're
controlling her and you're literally
like I die with a t-rex and we're just
we hate at this point in the stream we
hate it so much we're like we just want
to see people die because we're so
boring thanks but I was like Peter like
don't you know you're doing QTE stuff
just like Peter don't don't do it let
her die knees Peters like there's no way
they're gonna let her die t-rex comes
grabs lighter airier Terrier dog shake
it's just half a second after he said
that um yeah well you have yet to
announce the game tomorrow but it will
have dinosaurs maybe chat can help so
I'm thinking Tarak - yeah chap while
we're finishing up the show dinosaur
game which is arguing that they want to
play Dino Crisis is the obvious one but
that's like a decent game I did I like
the original
more lively games with the Resident Evil
kind of a third-person survival horror
um I'm gonna be playing more
battlegrounds I think what do you
playing this week Kelly I'm going to
f----- anime so I'm playing my sewing
machine where it
we're platforms out on where uh where is
Panem a San Jose
okay yeah bye you're reviewing like a
ton of games right now
yeah by that I mean to Friday 13th and
Tekken 7 yeah I want to write a review
for Ultra Street Fighter 2 the final
challengers for switch but that game is
Jupiter 2 is gonna release so many times
now and there's there's only a few
things I don't know
so we have like two arcade versions here
in the office we've won No yeah uh I'll
give you a live review sure maybe don't
buy it
second seven no Ultra Street Fighter 2
the final challenges gotcha okay it's
it's a it's a weird repackage and like
kind of remix of that game I just wanna
keep playing it justice - I really like
that game yeah I I wish I had more time
yeah what do you playing that I wanna
keep playing dead cells yeah that's all
if I have my choice that's what every
playing yeah anyway as always thank you
so much if you join in the YouTube or
twitch or GameSpot chat uh I think was
Chris something in the chat had a good
one
Yoshi's Island that's scene talk - I'm
thinking I'm thinking - rock - Turek one
fine game but not enough dinosaur isn't
it
in my opinion it's more bipedal weirdos
so rude - no 64 version if we have 64 I
would [ __ ] love - that's hard to get
alright that was remastered on PC rights
weekly yeah oh no you see that's why I'm
saying yeah alright yeah anime as always
thank you so much for joining whether
you're in YouTube twitch or on GameSpot
like I said go follow GameSpot on
Twitter if you haven't if you want one
of those for Call of Duty zombie posters
by Yoji Shinkawa the character artists
for Metal Gear Solid games yeah those
look really good
you can retweet that tweet and we'll
pick a winner randomly later in the week
apologies only in North America outside
of that Eric tell you John Luke psyche
and Richard Lee thank you for running
the show as always got the stream later
on it too for
Friday 13th got Dino DNA tomorrow we
will have I know Jake Decker and I will
be streaming something Monday we haven't
figured that out yet we are kinda just
playing what we talked about on reboot
our show but uh yeah got a lot of stuff
coming out this week and thanks as
always for joining we'll see you next
week same time 11:00 a.m. Pacific on
Wednesday